1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
bonjour je la recherche d'un homme voici
son portrait robot
vous connaissez n'existait pas le
colonel ça fait 25 ans qu'il a fait voeu
de silence tir salle du grenier
je pensais pas vous trouver six cases au
foot et là vous savez bien que j'ai plus
un circuit
écoutez faut pour revenir son sein la
vidéo pourra pas démarrer
- vous supplie à genoux mais mais je
suis pas là pour ça sans moi je passe
mon tour je suis bien ici j'ai trouvé
mon chez moi c'était pas facile au début
avec certains il ya un peu de tout ici
vous voyez les frères mario trois fois
condamné pour viol oui ça soit pas
retouché pas qu'ici qu'on ne voit pas
regardez ça je suis bien ici les gens
sont sympas personne ne me jugent bon il
ya quelques bagarres parfois mais
finalement c'est rien et puis
l'important c'est que j'ai enfin trouvé
la paix alors sérieusement colonel
pourquoi est ce que j'irai deux nouveaux
fours aimons et dans toutes ces
conneries tiens je crois que c'est
réparé écoutez grenier vous déplacez pas
ici tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'on a besoin de vous alors oubliez
passé fait un flash back enlever cet
heureux qui revenait je rappelle de ce
moment quand j'étais là avec j'ai dit ça
lui connaît c'est peut-être trop récents
comme flash back
non finalement je me souviens quand
j'étais à la guerre c'est en 1988 ce je
faisais partie de toutes ces excellentes
adaptations de films en jeux vidéo comme
timecop le cinquième élément ou street
fighter street fighter le jeu le jeu du
film du film tiré du jeu bref ce jeu
était lui tirer de l'excellent film de
guerre platon
l'at-on la philosophie dans tiger attend
non non non c'était platoon le film
voilà ce jeu avait une superbe intro en
fait une des intros les plus belles que
j'avais jamais vu pour un jeu nes
dommage que personne ne l'ait jamais vu
puisque pour lancer les trop il fallait
attendre une minute trente sur les
grands titres d'intro sans rien toucher
sérieusement qui va attendre une minute
et trente secondes sur l'écran titre
d'un jeu sans rien faire alors que tout
ce qui se passe pendant ce temps ses
défauts score qui défilent et le nom des
éditeurs trois fois j'essayais
d'imaginer quelle circonstance pouvait
emmener quelqu'un ne pas appuyer sur un
bouton pendant une minute trente sur un
écran titre parce que j'ai pas trois
c'est une bonne raison site appuyait sur
le bouton le jeu des marais et eut raté
toutes les explications du scénario
d'ailleurs les explications dans ce jeu
c'est tout ce qui manque et tout le
niveau or se faisait dans un labyrinthe
vrai labyrinthe les viets était malin on
croyait arriver dans une jungle dense et
au lieu de ça ils avaient tailler les
haies bien proprement ça me rappelait
une autre guerre que j'avais dû livrer
au labyrinthe d'alice à disneyland
là aussi j'avais dû rebuter des mecs
pour sortir des intermittents du
spectacle avaient menacé de me couper la
tête je n'ai pas me laisser faire
en fait 90 % des gens qui avaient eu ce
jeu n'ont même pas réussi à franchir
cette étape de la forêt pour une raison
simple à ses crocs n'avait pas de carte
je suppose que les génies qui nous ont
envoyés ici se sont dit que ça serait
marrant de se perdre pendant trois
heures dans une telle forêt où tous se
ressembler août à rien pour t'orienter
même le manuel se foutent de notre
gueule nouveau conseillant de faire une
carte de cet endroit pour ne pas vous
perdre
qui disait ah bah merci merci du conseil
c'est clair que j'éprouve un immense
plaisir à mettre la poste toutes les
cinq secondes pour faire un plan de
merde sur une feuille de merde merde il
aurait marqué que ça aurait été pareil
le meilleur moment de ce passage dans la
forêt c'est clairement cet instant
magique où tu t'aperçois que ton plan
est foirée et ne correspond à rien
le problème c'est qu'ils essayaient
dresser une carte de cette forêt c'est
un peu comme essayer de télécharger te
le porno du monde tu te dis qu'avec
beaucoup de patience se finira par y
arriver mais on sait tous que c'est
impossible
non mais sérieusement regarder mes
tentatives de plans j'aurai plus de
chance de retrouver mon chemin dans la
forêt du film de la witch pourtant je
sais pas c'est pas compliqué il aurait
suffit de mettre sur certains tableaux
un élément de décor unique un truc qui
permettent de tenir à mais oui je suis
déjà passé par là mais non c'est
tellement plus amusant d'essayer de
retrouver son chemin parmi une centaine
de tableaux tous complètement identique
sérieusement regarder à quoi ressemble
cette forêt d'après un plan trouver sur
le net
[Musique]
ce qui est génial avec cette carte c'est
que quand tu trace l'itinéraire tu te
rends compte à quel point qui serait
jamais arrivé sans cela la plupart des
jeux même dans les labyrinthes les
chemins vont généralement dans la
direction générale de gauche à droite
ici il faut aller chercher les explosifs
au sud-est après revenir à l'ouest puis
au nord puis à l'ouest de nouveau passer
derrière notre point de départ puis à
l'est puis au sud et au nord de nouveau
nom d'une pipe
c'est à peine si à cette époque j'arrive
à faire les labyrinthes aux données
paquet de chocapic alors comment est ce
que vous voulez que j'arrive à retrouver
mon chemin dans le labyrinthe était pas
le seul problème il fallait aussi invité
les viets qui me tombait dessus ses
faces de citron nous tomber dessus
tellement vite qu'on pouvait presque
jamais réagir l'état majeur nous avait
bien donné des grenades pour donner
forme et bordel on n'arrivait jamais à
les lancer en moins de 3 secondes ça
servait carrément à rien en fait dès
qu'on voyait un vix est arrivé nos buts
est toujours avant que la grenade le
tube [ __ ] fait chier faut quand même
pas être bien qu pour pas comprendre
qu'une arme qui tue en trois secondes ça
sert à rien si l'ennemi de gens de
d'ailleurs maintenant j'ai compris
pourquoi on appelait les ennemis charlie
au vietnam
c'est parce qu'on n'arrivait jamais à
les trouver sérieusement regarder ça il
est planqué derrière le décor comment
est ce que vous voulez éviter des
ennemis derrière le décor laisse-moi
m'amuser merde ce jeu me stresser
tellement qui me donnait la chair de
poule
finalement au bout de plusieurs heures
j'ai trouvé le chemin du village
c'est ici que va servir cette barre de
morale parce que quand on tue des
villageois innocent vous comprenez que
notre moral baisse tout ça parce que
nous les américains on est là pour
protéger les populations tout ça je dois
dire que ce village était la parfaite
conclusion pour ce niveau de la forêt en
fait l'objectif c'était de rentrer dans
les maisons et de cliquer sur des objets
au hasard des fois ça marche et est 10
fois tu as obtenez un item qui te
servait pour le niveau suivant
et des fois ça marchait pas et humour
est tout simplement c'était uniquement
du hasard n'y avait rien qui est indiqué
sur quoi tu devais clic et voilà après
m'être cassé le cul pendant des heures
dans ce niveau de la forêt je crevais
ici tué par un sac de farine s'est elle
bien dans l'auto de la vie quoi non rien
je fais flash back complète c'est tout à
preuve un plus tu devrais pas faire de
flashback en mangeant en fait c'est pas
pratique
c'est là que j'avais abandonné la
mission et que j'avais arrêté c'était la
goutte d'eau qui avait mis le feu aux
poudres
j'en pouvais plus ce flashback était
terminée je devais rentrer chez moi mais
avant ça je te les comprendre ce que je
foutais ici
nous venons d'apprendre que le colonel a
été enlevée par le gang halmos tâches au
sein d'une mission de sauvetage
si personne ne finit metal gear dans les
24 heures je serai heureux
allez cette fois on rigole plus metal
gear sur nes n'empêche c'est bizarre de
se dire que cette série qui est pourtant
devenu aujourd'hui une des séries de
jeux vidéo les plus connus du monde a
commencé vraiment avec des jeux qui tu
es vraiment pas terrible et pourtant
c'est bien les premiers jeux metal gear
qui ont installé les trucs les plus
connus aujourd'hui du genre le coup du
point d'exclamation quand tu te faire
opérer le coût du carton extra alors
personnellement comme beaucoup de gens
j'ai découvert m'établir qu'avec la
version playstation sorti en 1999 et
metal gear solid c'était loin d'être le
premier metal girin le premier metal
gear ce test ou simplement d'un métal
gier sorti en 1987 sur msx version à
laquelle a participé d'ailleurs hideo
kojima le créateur de metal gear
alors cette version msx elle a été
ensuite adapté sur nes c'était pourri et
c'est celui dont je vous parlais et
d'ailleurs vous l'aurez remarqué je
prononce sa métal gier et non pas metal
gear et ya deux raisons à cela la
première c'est que j'ai été induit en
erreur quand j'étais jeune par les pubs
pour la gaine girpi gilles la première
console portable couleurs de ces
derniers et depuis c'est resté
et la seconde c'est que j'adore faire
chier les gens
donc tout ça commence par la cinématique
de ce que je suppose être votre équipe
sautant d'un avion pour une mission
périlleuse et le jeu commence par vous
tout seul sans arme d'accord qu'est ce
qui s'est passé entre cet écran est
celui là où sont passés tes potes et
beaupré pour les armes je dis rien c'est
habituel c'est la crise ma bonne dame ce
n'est qu'ils commencent tous ces jeux
sans armes
la seule chose dans mon inventaire c'est
un paquet de clopes ça va bien mais 17
pour tuer des ennemis à ahvaz y respire
la fumée et d'ici vingt ou trente ans le
tabagisme passif te tuera et je pourrais
passer alors m'établir c'est vraiment le
jeu qui a popularisé la figuration
alors bon forcément c'était plus évident
visuellement dans la version playstation
que de la version nes je veux dire par
ici par exemple tu peux choisir de tuez
le garde ou d'attendre jusqu'à ce qu'ils
disent je m'appelle
en criant un comportement normal chez
une personne fatiguée alors le souci
avec des gardes c'est que leur réaction
est jamais prévisible en fait là tenez
par exemple le mec je suis à trois
mètres devant ses yeux et il s'endort
devant moi ça doit être une équipe de
mercenaires narcoleptique où je sais pas
pas très efficace est à l'opposé des
fois va savoir comment ils te gris sans
même regarder dans ta direction pareil
sillage tabassent un mec à deux mètres
de son pote sans aucun problème il
réagit absolument pas et là je sors
d'une salle et je me fais un stand qu'il
part des gardes sans même que je puisse
réagir quoi ça aurait été cool de
trouver un juste milieu dans le
comportement des gardes quand même bon
alors heureusement c'est pas très
pénalisant si vous fait repérer par
exemple si vous faites repéré il suffira
de sortir de l'écran là est en fait
magie on vous voit plus et ça marche
pour tous 1 vous rentrez par exemple
dans un camion qui remplit de garde
pas de problème vous sortez du camion et
les gardes ils s'arrêtent ils sont pas
payés pour sortir du camion c'est pas
leur boulot
qu'est ce qu'on fait on poursuit donc
bref une fois que vous avez hâte à la
base c'est là que les choses marrantes
commence donc premièrement vous allez
récupérer votre première clé magnétique
alors le jeu entier va fonctionner avec
ses clés c'est à dire que quand vous
serez dans les bâtiments toutes les
portes et j'ai bien dit toutes les
portes demanderont une clé magnétique
pour s'ouvrir
vous savez après 30 ans de jeux vidéo
maintenant on considère certains trucs
comme évident par exemple dans un jeu
aujourd'hui il nous semblerait pas
normal de ne pas avoir un système du
type d'un lac les rouges et ouvre la
porte rouge et la porte s'ouvre
automatiquement des colonna proche avec
la bonne clé en poche ou alors
simplement en appuyant sur un bouton
d'action mais pour ce jeu il n'y avait
pas ça ben alors au début ça va hein
quand vous avez qu'une seule clé ou deux
bons vous à devant une porte faut aller
dans le menu sélectionnez la clé appuyé
sur b hélas la porte s'ouvre mais sauf
c'est que ce jeu il est très long et
qu'à la fin du jeu c'est pas une clé que
tu as ces huit clé que la porte donc
elles s'ouvrent pas automatiquement
quand une approche et que les portes et
n'indiquent absolument pas à quelle clé
et correspondent
est ce que vous comprenez à quel stade
de chiante is inter spatiale c'est
d'ouvrir une porte dans ce
je sais pas là quatre noms mais la
moindre porte que vous rencontrez c'est
le même délire le même cirque qui
recommence c'est pas la 3 la deux tamer
carte une allée ohlala est ce que vous
comprenez à quel point ce truc casse
complètement le rythme du jeu
franchement c'est comme des pop up de
pub sur un site porno c'est ça je l' ai
lu sur wikipédia
cependant je cherche un porto à l'écart
de huit
non c'est pas la carte but évidemment ça
va être comme quand tu cherches tu écris
dans les poches c'est forcément dans la
[ __ ] deux dernières poches oberlé
ouvre-toi sérieux aird
non mais une minute pour ouvrir une
porte
il ya une porte tous les dix mètres
autres délires avec les cartes assez tôt
dans le début du jeu vous allez ramasser
un masque à gaz ce masque vous sert pour
passer des salles remplies de gaz mais
le problème c'est que pour entrer dans
cette salle il faut utiliser une clé est
que si vous utilisez une clé vous ne
pouvez pas utiliser le masque parce que
parce que vous êtes un héros de jeu
vidéo et que donc vous ne pouvez pas
faire des choses parfaitement sensées du
genre à voir un masque sur la tête et
une carte dans la main non
donc du coup il faut utiliser la carte
qui au passage se fait automatiquement
rentrer dans la salle avec le gaz ce qui
veut dire que si tu rentres dedans on
est en bas en énergie battu crée
instantanément c'est génial ensuite
immédiatement dans la salle il faut
appuyer sur select pour mettre le masque
à gaz parce que govou 6 ans forcément
sinon vous perdez d'énergie ensuite il
faut aller jusqu à notre porte
enlevez le masque à gaz en étant encore
dans la salle immédiatement appuyé sur
ses led pour sélectionner la carte pour
sortir de la salle comment tu peux foire
est un truc à cinq points mais celle
croyable quoi c'est pourtant simple en
fin de programme et une porte c'est pas
eu d'élément compliqué dans un jeu je
sais pas attendez ce n'est pas fini
encore mieux parce que la danse est
salta qu'une carte donc ça va c'est
complètement con ok tu peux pas
sélectionner la carte en gardant le
masque à gaz ce qui fait que tu prends
des dégâts d'accord mais c'est facile il
juste d'être rapide sur le bouton select
mais maintenant imaginez cette scène
avec huit cartes
donc bref retour à la scène précédente
où je cherchais mes cartes
j'adore cet effet donc là je rentre dans
la salle en utilisant la carte numéro 5
je mets le masque je vais jusqu'à
l'autre bout de la salle et là paf une
mine
donc je me disais je vais utiliser le
détecteur de mines
évidemment c'est utile de détecteurs de
mines sur obligé d'enlever le masque à
gaz ces gens et vas-y choisi comment tu
veux mourir les bines le gazon néo
colons très ce choix donc bref comme les
mines fait moins de dégâts j'ai choisi
de marcher sur les mines comme un con
ensuite arrive à la porte et là tu crois
que ça va être la carte 5 pour sortir de
la salle ça serait logique non un tueur
entrer dedans avec la carte de 5 mais
non c'est pas ça
alors tu te dis que peut-être ça va être
une des dernières cartes 1 ça serait
logique après tout puisque c'est le
dernier bâtiment je suis presque au boss
de fin du jeu donc ça devrait peut-être
être la carte 6 7 8 a fait une des
dernières cartes en main dont évidemment
à la corde qu'il faut utiliser c'est la
carte vrai dakar que tu a ramassé par
terre
au tout début du jeu il ya des heures
donc tu essaies toutes les cartes une
par une en perdant de l'énergie puis
finalement quand tu as trouvé la bonne
tu passé la bouée oui tu arrives dans
une salle avec un seul électrifiée et là
il faut courir sur l'électricité puis
mangé une ration à mi parcours pour les
jeunes foule vie est là quand tu arrives
au bout que tu te dépêches de sortir de
la salle et c'est normal parce que c'est
calculé pour que tu sois juste à deux
doigts de crever à la fin de la salle
donc que le réflexe de sortir de la
salle pour te mettre à l'abri et là
derrière la porte et kate et gagna
l'étape à 8 4 mecs qui te bun
instantanément quand tu passes la carte
et quand tu perds tu repars complètement
à l'autre bout de la carte
y'a pas un genre de loi qui condamne les
tentatives au long terme être des trous
du cul sérieux mais je veux savoir qui a
réussi à finir ce jeu sans sol us j'ai
peur
[Musique]
elle table
un des problèmes de ce jeu c'est que si
tu étais pas dans la tête des
développeurs pour en comprendre la
logique tu ne peux pas le terminer il ya
par exemple parmi les trucs qui m'ont
soul et moi y avait ce char ce char tu
vas le croiser très tôt au début du jeu
tu sais pas quand est-ce que tu dois le
passé c'est pas indiquée par le scénario
et je veux dire j'ai vidé mes munitions
de su quoi dire quand bien même ce
serait parfaitement logique de réussir à
détruire un char avec des missiles ou
avec des packs de c4 mais non le jeu il
n'a pas prévu ça alors le c4 c'est pour
les ordinateurs les missiles c'est pour
les interrupteurs et pour les sharks et
les villes attendait c'est complètement
con les trois sets explosifs non parce
que ml c'est pour les chars parce que
c'est moi qui décide qu est-ce qui fait
sur quoi
voilà donc la seule arme qui lui fait
mal ce sont les mines 11 mines
précisément il faut poser 11 mines sous
ce char sans que rien n'indique qu'il
prenne le moindre dégât
rien aucun clignotement de l'engin pour
indiquer qui prend un coup aucun bruit
rien n'importe qui de logique
abandonnerait au bout de la cinquième ou
de la sixième tentative en se disant ben
merde je sais pas la bonne technique
j'arrête parce que là je suis en train
de gâcher mes munitions
mais non c'est bien la bonne technique
mais la cerise c'est que si tu vis des
armes dessus que tu sort de l'écran en
te disant que c'est pas la bonne chose à
faire quand tu reviens dans l'écran le
char est remis à neuf et donc tu dois
tout retourné à l'autre bout de la caf
pour aller rechercher des mines pour de
nouveau tout recommencer et ça
évidemment il ya aucun dialogue dans le
jeu qui te dit pour tds et franchement
d'une façon d'une manière générale et
dialogues dans ce jeu sont pas très
utiles
j'ai oublié de tenir il ya des bars ont
installé aux fenêtres du toit pense à
chercher une tenue de déminage
[Musique]
ce jeu est très très long j'ai à peine
effleuré la surface alors il ya plein
d'autres trucs à dire en bien comme en
mal
mais je vous garde quand même la fin
avec plaisir la fin de ce jeu c'est un
espèce d'enchaînements de trucs débiles
comme s'il avait confié le développement
du jeu à l'asile de maboule du coin
alors gère pour commencer l'accès au
dernier bâtiment pour le rejoindre tu
dois passer par non tu pardon tu doit
deviner qu'il faut passer par là parce
que pour une fois le jeu de te donne
aucun indice ni aucune explication notez
et là vous voyez bien que l'écran se
répète en boucle à moi qui suis
complètement jeu tarbais où que tu
ailles c'est la même chose
regardez là je vais à gauche là je vais
en haut là je vais en bas c'est la même
chose on est d'accord et bien donc cet
écran qui se répètent en boucle avec
cinq chemins différents
il faut aller à gauche encore à gauche
ou à droite est de nouveau à gauche et
mais voilà c'était facile à attendait
comment calculer les statistiques au
lycée cinq chemins possibles qui ont en
outre cinq de plus qui en ouvre de
nouveau 5 de plus attendez mais ça fait
pas des centaines de possibilités ça ils
sont malades mais les mecs sera pas bien
dans vos têtes
après tu as tout le dernier bâtiment
avec les histoires de gaz de clé de sol
électrifié de trous lg je veux parler
des trous et pourtant ce jeu on est
remplie elle jardine 40 dans une salle
et là paf trousses ouvre juste devant
toi tu peux rien faire et aussi
carrément des fois tu rentres dans une
seule et la salle est piégé par un trou
géant merci [ __ ] mais j'ai le bord de
la sho sur le bord de la chaussée en
contact avec le noir comment est ce que
je peux mourir je suis même pas dedans
[ __ ] ah non tu m'auras pas tu veux pas
toucher les arbitres ensuite on a le
dernier ordinateur quand tu le pet un
timer se déclenche et tu l'as tu es le
boss avant la fin
de temps tu peux toujours fumer une
clope parce que les clubs donne plus de
temps c'est bien connu
et puis quand tu as tu es le boss tu
dois t'échapper et là vous vous demandez
mais pourquoi yat-il trois portes que
pour sortir mais mon petit mais c'est
parce qu'il y en a deux défenses
évidemment et comme toi même quand tu as
tu es le boss on s'assure que tu es
quand même qu'une chance sur trois de
voir la cinématique de fin parce que
nous chez konami on adore [ __ ] des
[ __ ] d'ascenseur qui vont nulle part
vous aimez le gravier le fair play alors
jouer des hadjis regard dix ans d'un
solide
[Musique]
vous savez je commence très sérieusement
à croire qu'ils avaient un psychopathe
qui travaillait chez konami à cette
époque à temps ils ont fait quoi comme
jeu déjà après m'établir mais hors du
commun monde a même mis des mots de
passe si vous avez envie de réessayer la
fin du jeu le mot de passe c'est fuck be
avec plus de 1 derrière voilà donc je ne
sais pas si c'est un appel à l'aide le
cachet de la part d'un des développeurs
mais pour moi quand le mot de passe qui
t'amène à la fin du jeu s'appelle [ __ ]
moi c'était un problème quelque part
mais non sérieusement bon je sais comme
dit l'expression faut pas jeter le bébé
avec l'eau du butin mais là je peux
décemment pas considérer metal gear
comme étant un bon jeu il ya trop de
trucs qui gâche ton plaisir en
permanence alors j'adore la licence mais
la nostalgie stains excuse pas tout ah
oui accessoirement alors bon à ce stade
c'est plus qu'un détail mais à aucun
moment dans le jeu on ne voit le métal
gier ainsi tu sais le robot géant là le
métal jir le truc qui donne le titre aux
jeux là il paraît elle et ça suffit les
conneries mais non c'est la guerre
[Musique]
fini de rigoler c'est l'heure de
l'action
[Musique]
la région
la moustache
à
[Musique]
colonel je vais vous délivrez je sais
pas trop tôt a demandé ma vie en appoint
non service bleus de printemps bethesda
sur la tête je veux sortir d'ici
[Musique]
50 ans ne sont pas suffisamment franchir
et
vous faites une wave et avoir toulouse
de newmarket aino et aussi
paris - lyon
[Musique]
enfin
là